Let's look at the solution for
a write-back cache quiz.
When we have read A, we're going to
check the tag and the valid bit.
The tag matches A, but
the valid bit is 0, so this is a miss.
Now, we have one miss.
We will make the valid bit be 1.
The tag becomes A.
This is a read, so the dirty bit is 0.
Note that the fact that
the dirty big was one,
doesn't matter here because
this was not valid.
So it simply doesn't matter what's here,
if valid bit is zero for that line.
Next, we read B.
We check the tag and the valid bit.
The tag is a mismatch,
so this is a miss.
We have a miss, we need to kick out A.
For that, we check the dirty bit.
It's zero, so
we don't have a write back.
We replace A with B here.
The valid bit is 1.
The dirty bit is 0
because this is a read.
Next, we have a write to B.
Check the tag and the valid bit.
This is a hit, so it's not a miss.
Because this is a write,
we set the dirty bit.
Next we read C.
Check the tag.
Mismatch.
This is a miss.
We need to replace B.
So we check, is it dirty?
Yes, it is.
We need to write back B to memory.
Then, we can bring in C.
Set its valid bit to 1.
And because this is a read,
the dirty bit becomes 0.
Next, we read D.
It's a miss.
We need to kick out C.
C is clean, so
we don't have a right back.
We just bring in D and
overwrite C in the cache.
It's a read, so the dirty bit is 0 and
the valid bit is 1,
because the tag is valid.
Next, we have a write to D.
It's a hit, but
the dirty bit changes to 1.
So overall,
we had 1 write-back and 4 misses.
And the state of the cache is that
the valid bit is 1, the dirty bit is 1,
and the tag corresponds to D.